[Music]
the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers previously on The Walking Dead
on his trailer from the network behind
some of your favorite shows prequel
spin-offs comes the phenomenon that
shows no signs of stopping its attempts
to get you to watch into the Badlands
turn and that train won The Walking Dead
you've stuck with a Walking Dead for
almost six years and no matter how
predictable it gets you've sunk too much
of your life into it to stop now settle
in for yet another block of eight
episodes with two great ones two good
ones and four hours of pure filler Oh
pick me up when you get there guys meet
what's left of the group Rick who's
either in charge or completely nuts
depending on how grimy his beer looks
Karl his puddin love and son who's been
infected by enough puberty to make an H
five years in a year and a half long
story Daryl and Michonne the silent
badasses with the strongest weapon of
all fans support these two guys who were
so faithful to the graphic novels that
they feel like cartoons and Carol the
meek emotionally scarred victim who did
you kill Karen and David yes wait what
damn
oh the monsters and they will tear you
apart
and eat you up all while you're still
alive
oh you can still feel it damn Carol you
scary strap in for a show
packed with countless characters but
just one story of the group finding a
safe haven that eventually gets
destroyed again and again this place can
be home and again perfect and again
welcome to wood burn and again welcome
to terminus
and again welcome to Alexandria
hmm I wonder where negan lives I can't
wait for them to bug that town next
season in a world where undead danger
used to lurk around every corner
watch as surviving the apocalypse takes
a backseat to less threatening more
stretched out plots that don't go
anywhere like five episodes of the flu
seven episodes about finding baths that
end up with baths dying not one but two
flashback episodes about the governor
and after seven episodes building up to
the group being trapped by a fortress
full of cannibals is screwing with the
wrong people they immediately blow it up
and move on you fast forward it through
the cannibals why to get back to more
woods walking stay with the cannibals
could have cleaned that place up and
made a barbecue pit out of it or
something so gear up for a show built on
the premise that any main character can
die at any moment
that's devolved into a show where any
supporting character can die at any
moment
that's even further devolved into a show
where apparently no one can die even if
they're clearly eaten by a massive herd
of friggin zombies ah I need a break hey
what's up guys be sure to join us at the
dishonest trailer for only talking
positively about The Walking Dead
tonight's guests are somebody who died
from the show a random celebrity who may
not have ever seen the show and a
producer that I cannot be critical of
others I might lose my job points
storing more bug ly cry-face more
improbable headshots
more group debate I have to talk all of
you in the rest of the council they
wanted me to talk to you
we're going to talk about what happened
we can talk to them
we will people losing it
guys no mending fences
I forgive you
literally mending fences in our eight
kids club
one off expendable characters whose
debts will have zero emotional impact on
the viewer walking
[Music]
straddle budging
more walking digging even more walking
[Music]
Darryl chowing down
gross a truly staggering amount of
actual walking
[Music]
and coral Oh yawn of the Dead they can't
keep this up forever can they uh be sure
to subscribe for more honest trailers
hey screen junkies if you're a real
Walking Dead head be sure to check out
our brand new recap and review show
knockin dead where we break down
everything Walker related from each
week's episode of The Walking Dead
it's like talking dead but we're allowed
to be honest go ahead click the box
above and tell him coral sent you don't
dead open inside rainbow dust in a fart
bucket carry on my wayward son the world
is a cruel place
see you later space donkey get back here
Jessica now Jessica he'll probably
strike upon thee with great die hard
with a vengeance and Nick furious anger